>> Jason: 2019 BROUGHT US
UKRAINEGATE, A DANCING
SEAN SPICER ON A PROMISE NOT TO
SHOW YOU THAT VIDEO.
I PROMISE.
THE END OF THE "GAME OF THRONES"
AND LIBERAL PURITY ON CAMPUSES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
HERE TODAY BECAUSE THROUGH IT
ALL IS CHARLIE KIRK.
TURNING POINT USA FOUNDER AND
AUTHOR OF AN UPCOMING BOOK "THE
MAGA DOCTRINE."
YOU ARE GOING TO WANT TO GET
THIS ONE.
I WANT TO START WITH ONE OF THE
MOST EGREGIOUS EXAMPLES OF
CONSERVATIVES BEING TARGETED AND
ATTACKED.
A RECRUITER WAS HARASSED AND
PUNCH IN THE FACE AT
UC BERKELEY.
WATCH.
>> [BLEEP]
[BLEEP]
>> Jason: I MEAN, HE JUST WENT
RIGHT SMACK DAB AFTER HIM.
WHAT WAS HAPPENING THERE?
>> THAT WAS OUR TURNING POINT
USA GROUP AT UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY.
HAYDEN WILLIAMS WAS RECRUITING
STUDENTS.
WE UNDERSTAND WE ARE NOT GOING
TO BE IN THE IDEOLOGICAL
MAJORITY AT UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY BUT AS
CONSERVATIVES, WE STILL WANT TO
GO OUT AND TRY TO RECRUIT ANY
STUDENTS THAT MIGHT ALIGN WITH
OUR BELIEF SYSTEM.
THIS LEFTIST THUG CAME UP AND
SMACKED HIM IN THE FACE.
HERE'S THE SAD PART ABOUT THIS.
THAT WAS IN FEBRUARY.
THIS CASE HAS BASICALLY GONE
COLD.
HE PLEADED GUILTY.
THE D.A. IS STILL SITTING ON IT,
NO TRIAL.
I'VE BEEN TALKING TO HAYDEN
WILLIAMS.
HE'S JUST WAITING FOR JUSTICE
AND I'M AFRAID THAT THERE'S BEEN
THIS PATTERN AT BERKELEY THAT IF
YOU DO PHYSICAL VIOLENCE AGAINST
A CONSERVATIVE SUCH AS PROFESSOR
WHO SMACKED SOMEONE WITH A BIKE
LOCK NOT TOO LONG AGO, YOU MIGHT
GET AWAY WITH IT.
YOU SAW THAT VIDEO, CONSIDERING
GETTING PUNCHED IN THE FACE.
JUSTICE IS STILL HANGING.
I HOPE THE D.A. DOES THE RIGHT
THING BUT I'M NOT TOO CONFIDENT.
THAT WAS ONE OF THE MORE
EGREGIOUS EXAMPLES THAT LED TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP SIGNING THE
HISTORIC EXECUTIVE ORDER TO
PROTECT FREE SPEECH ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
I HOPE WE CAN GET JUSTICE FOR
HAYDEN.
>> Jason: IMPORTANT THING WHEN
DONALD TRUMP TO BUT IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT WHAT YOU'RE DOING
THESE COLLEGE CAMPUSES IN GIVING
VOICE, EVEN IN A PLACE WHERE
THEY MIGHT BE A MINORITY.
LET'S HEAD DOWN TO
NORTH CAROLINA WHERE A
CONSERVATIVE STUDENT, THIS IS
THE SON OF CONGRESSMAN DAN
BISHOP.
HE WAS ACTUALLY SPRAY-PAINTED IN
THE FACE.
THOSE ACTIVISTS WERE ACTUALLY
TRYING TO COVER UP ADS JACK
BISHOP POSTED FEATURING EVENT
FEATURING YOU.
>> WE WERE ACCOSTED BY A FEW
MEMBERS OF THE CLUB HERE, THEY
WERE EXPRESSING FREE SPEECH AND
THESE PEOPLE ROLLED UP IN A
CONCERTED, INTENTIONAL,
PREPLANNED ATTEMPT TO CENSOR OUR
SPEECH.
I THINK IT'S INDICATIVE OF
WHAT'S GOING ON IN CAMPUSES.
>> Jason: TELL ME WHAT YOU
LEARNED ABOUT THAT CASE,
CHARLIE.
>> I WANT YOUR AUDIENCE TO THINK
FOR A SECOND.
IMAGINE IF A MOB OF STUDENTS
WEARING MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN
HATS WENT UP TO A LIBERAL
STUDENT AND SPRAY-PAINTED THAT
STUDENT BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T LIKE
WHAT THEY WERE SAYING.
IMAGINE THE OUTRAGE.
OF COURSE, THE MEDIA
CONVENIENTLY DIDN'T COVER THIS
DESPITE THERE BEING VIDEO
EVIDENCE OF A LEFTIST MOB THAT
CAME UP TO HIM.
THE CAMPUS TOUR AT
NORTH CAROLINA STATE UNIVERSITY.
UNFORTUNATELY, AGAIN, VERY
LITTLE JUSTICE WAS SERVED.
THE ADMINISTRATION DIDN'T
ADDRESS AT THE WAY WE WOULD'VE
LIKED BUT THANKFULLY JACK IS
DOING MUCH BETTER.
AS YOU CAN SEE, MANY TURNING
POINT USA STUDENTS ARE UNDER
ATTACK FOR THEIR BELIEFS.
>> Jason: IT'S AMAZING TO ME
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
DOING THE ATTACKING ARE USUALLY
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE PREACHING
THE MOST TOLERANCE.
TOLERANCE, YOU'VE GOT TO ACCEPT
EVERYTHING.
THERE ENDS OF BEING THE LEAST
TOLERANT OF ALL OF THEM.
I HAVE TO TURN TO PENNSYLVANIA
WHERE TOM HOMAN, FORMER ACTING
I.C.E. DIRECTOR AT A FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR.
HE TRIED TO SPEAK AT AN EVENT
ABOUT IMMIGRATION, AS HE SERVED
UNDER PRESIDENTS OBAMA AND
TRUMP.
I SAY TRY BECAUSE LOOK AT WHAT
HAPPENED.
>> GO HOME!
GO HOME, HOMAN!
>> Jason: CHARLIE, CAMPUSES
ARE THE PLACES WHERE WE ARE
TRYING TO TEACH KIDS HOW TO
THINK AND HAVE A CIVIL DIALOGUE.
WHAT'S YOUR EXPERIENCE ACROSS
THE COUNTRY?
>> ALLEGEDLY.
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
MARKETPLACES OF IDEAS.
STUDENTS AT UNIVERSITY OF
PENNSYLVANIA, THEY ARE
CONSTANTLY WRONG WITH YOUR NEVER
IN DOUBT.
VERY QUICKLY, THEY DID DO
ANYTHING ABOUT WHAT TOM HOMAN
WAS TRYING TO ACTUALLY DO.
BY RUNNING I.C.E. IN RUNNING THE
IMMIGRATION SERVICES.
THEY WOULD KNOW THAT HE WENT
AFTER HER CHILD SEX TRAFFICKERS,
SOME OF THE WORST PEOPLE IN OUR
SOCIETY.
THEY DID WHAT MADE THEM FEEL
GOOD, NOT WHAT WOULD DO GOOD FOR
SOCIETY FOR THE COUNTRY.
>> Jason: TOM HOMAN SERVED
UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA.
I WANT TO RETURN TO NEW ORLEANS,
TULANE UNIVERSITY.
A MEMBER OF YOUR ORGANIZATION
FACED AN ARSON ATTACK.
YOU CAN SEE THE BURN MARKS ON
HIS DOOR RIGHT THERE.
WHAT ELSE HAPPENED?
>> HE TRIED TO START A TURNING
POINT USA GROUP AT TULANE
UNIVERSITY AND HAD HIS
DORMITORY, TRIED TO BE
FIREBOMBED.
THE POLICE INTERVENED QUICKLY
AND IN THE CORRECT WAY AND THE
PEOPLE THAT DID THIS WERE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
HIS PRIVATE INFORMATION WAS MADE
PUBLIC.
HE WAS DOXXED.
NO STUDENT SHOULD HAVE TO BE
FIREBOMBED BECAUSE THEY ARE
TRYING TO START A GROUP ON
EITHER THE RIGHT OR THE LEFT.
THIS IS JUST ANOTHER EXAMPLE IN
2019 OF THE LEFT NOT JUST
DISAGREEING WITH CONSERVATIVES
BUT TARGETING THEM AND PUTTING
THEM IN PHYSICAL DANGER.
>> Jason: THE LAST ONE WE HAVE
TIME FOR IS UNFORTUNATELY HAPPEN
IN MY HOME STATE OF UTAH.
HIGH SCHOOL SENIOR WAS ARRESTED
FOR RELEASING PEPPER SPRAY AT
THE SCHOOL TO STOP AN EVENT PUT
ON BY A LOCAL CHAPTER OF AGAIN,
TURNING POINT USA.
>> YEAH, YOU KNOW THAT AREA
WELL.
IT'S IN PARK CITY.
THE LEFT HATES THE IDEA THAT
THERE ARE OTHER IDEAS.
IMAGINE IF A CONSERVATIVE VISTA
LIBERALS.
I TELL YOU WHAT, THE FINAL THING
I'LL SAY IS WE WILL NOT ALLOW
THE LEFT TO BULLY OUR STUDENTS
OR INTIMATE US GOING INTO 2020.
IT'S HARDER THAN EVER BUT WE ARE
MORE RESOLVED TO CONTINUE TO WIN
ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
RATES WE DO
LISTEN, GOOD LUCK TO YOU BECAUSE
GOING INTO 2020, I THINK THINGS
ARE GOING TO GET EVEN MORE
VOLATILE.
HATS OFF TO THOSE STUDENTS THAT
ARE WILLING TO STAND UP FOR WHAT
THEY PERSONALLY BELIEVE AND
TURNING POINT USA FOR
CHALLENGING AND ENCOURAGING AND
INVITING CONSERVATIVES TO